God made earbuds for a reason and if you
don't have earbuds that's your problem
use subtitles I don't know I don't care
just as long as I never have to hear any
sounds emitting from that little box you
carry around in your pocket or better
yet if you're sitting at a restaurant
and um you're alone nothing wrong with
that by the way I'm a big proponent of
you know eating a lot of restaurant can
be very therapeutic but if you find
yourself in that situation
and you don't have earphones
and there's there's no way to listen to
something or watch something on your
phone without being a Monumental jerk to
everyone around you well have you
considered the possibility that you
don't need to be on your phone at all
have you considered
sitting there and eating and not doing
anything else but those two things this
was like a normal
currents for people all throughout human
history up until right now there would
be many occasions where you're just sort
of like
sitting somewhere and you're not you're
not doing anything else
and so then you're thinking
and that's that's the benefit you can
actually develop your own thoughts